well let me let me ask you I mean you
know two women presenting at WWDC
yesterday people are celebrating the
fact I mean how happy about that are
your is it somewhat patronizing and sad
that we need to you know that we need to
look at this the first women on stage in
five years and make a big deal out of it
I mean here we are I mean we could do a
happy dance if we really wanted to but
of course this should have been a long
time coming you know there's not just
one type of person working at Apple or
one type of person working in the tech
industry so you know it's great that
Apple has done it because they're a very
iconic company one that many companies
want to emulate big companies small
companies want to be like apples so I
guess I'm thankful I suppose Robin a
breakthrough or first step in a long
journey frightening I think it's the
first step I think it's it's really
important and I think it is a step and
so I applaud them for that but I think
it's you know time to step up absolutely
and in fact you know I was reading
Twitter yesterday during the
presentation and all I saw is people
complaining about the fact that there
weren't enough people of color in fact
where there were no people of color so
clearly Apple does have a long way to go
well when you think about it the number
of women in tech roles is less than 18%
and the number of you know diversity
people of color is less than 90% I
believe so it's pretty representative of
what's going on there
so I want to read something that Tim
Cook said yesterday in the run-up to
WWDC about gender diversity he said
quote I think it's our fault our meaning
the whole tech community I think in
general we haven't done enough to reach
out and show young women that it's cool
to do it and how much fun it can be
Robin do you agree with that absolutely
it's a cultural problem I mean the
problem is the perception it's the
stereotype when you think if you ask a
young woman what a coder looks like they
automatically think it's a man they
think you have to be sitting in the
basement eating stale pizza and drinking
Red Bull you know and we have to change
that image it's change happening at a
fast enough rate are you satisfied with
you know all the diversity reports the
the more diverse diversified presenters
at these conferences as a satisfying
deal you know I wish things would go
faster but I think a lot of people wish
that what's great is yes there is change
we just had Tim sitting here on
table from Pandora the 40% of Tim's
company is diverse from from a gender
perspective companies like Pandora
follow in their footsteps we have Etsy
we have Eventbrite we also have lifts
these are companies that we've
recognized that women 2.0 through our
awards to show that there are a number
of companies that are not filling in to
the old stereotype of beer pong and hot
tubs that you would see in Silicon
Valley so along with making tech cool
it's got to be interesting to work at
these companies and you know Pandora's
doing a great job in that respect and
you know we need to see more companies
step up to the plate and create a
culture that's inclusive robyn quickly
your film dived into this who are the
organizations you think are advocating
and successfully advocating for change
well I think I think a lot of them are
advocating for change I think the ones
that have actually done it
you mentioned Etsy Etsy's doing a really
good job they have increased from I
think it was like 8 percent to over 30
percent of their female engineers on
their on their engineering team I know
that IndieGoGo has done a really good
job also increasing women it's a
complicated issue it's not that easy I
think that diversifying your interview
panel is something that really helps